tem uma frase que não sai da boca da sua
mãe que é essa daqui ó esses menino um
dia vamos enlouquecer vamos não sabe
quem enlouquece ela só mãe enlouquece
sozinha só ela não precisa de filho para
enlouquecer não vou lhe dar um exemplo
bem breve você tá comendo almoçando né
Normal todo mundo almoça isso é normal
meio-dia ali 1 hora da tarde enquanto
você tá comendo ela tá lavando
louça enquanto ela lava a louça ela
conversa com outra mãe que tem dendo da
cabeça dela
e começa a enlouquecer sozinho pode
prestar atenção ó o cara tá comendo ela
tá lavando na louça ela fica assim ó
pração tem quem lave né Ó ali onde é que
tá ó
comendo só presta para comer na hora que
eu terminar de lavar ele chega com prato
e pã pra jumenta
relvar